[Music]
hey
folks here we are we might be drunk
we're doing it we're back i haven't seen
you face to face i saw you on the street
the other day and we talked for a minute
but i haven't actually yeah yeah we're
walking down manila lane and boom you
pop up and yeah then now we're on the
sidewalk doing a podcast i heard your
voice and i was like what
so where do your friend's voice that you
also like yeah it's just i don't know
yeah but that's because you're such a
recognizable voice sure that's really
what i get at like airports some guy's
like
comedian
so i gotta i got so much to talk to you
and then you go into the next men's room
yeah
damn it i messed that joke up and i tap
on the floor you know a little gay code
yeah republicans good to see you oh
google pitch
good to have you
are you okay with that name i don't want
to offend you all right all right
i like the theme of shirts you got going
on it's all i wear i like it well lion
is cool it came back for a minute yeah
now it's bad i think it was like a proud
boy movement where they kind of co-opted
for five minutes really yeah they were
called the boogaloo boys
oh but they were khaki pants and i don't
do that no okay you kind of look like
kramer's weird friend
bob sacramento yeah
proud boys and hawaiian shirts i'm like
no one is less laid-back than the proud
boys you know they're like we're gonna
kill you
they're shaking on ak-47
that's wild now we got the beer jew
cooking up a
those those look like summery drinks
what do we have they're pretty summery
they're old new york drinks as well
here today we have the salty dog i love
a salty dog i figured you would oh i
forgot about this
uh this is artie's drink from larry
sanders
he wants his salty dogs i love that
devito anthony devito when you do the
road he wants a salty dog that's a great
term too that guy's a salty dog you know
sounds like it's something you'd say
about a guy in an old bar
oh boy what is that a grapefruit on
there yeah that is really good not bad
right so that's what is it just
grapefruit and and vodka basically it's
just grapefruit and vodka uh if you're
using like store-bought grapefruit it's
gonna be a little sweeter so add a
little bit of lime juice because the
salt will make it sweet will like
accentuate the the sweetness as well
and like the original the salty dog is
just the greyhound with salt on the rim
and
uh
the greyhound was like just uh this
drink that was invented in like the 30s
or the 20s or the 30s yeah who you ask
funny that that used to be a classy term
i'll have a gray hat yeah
now you're like you're on the greyhound
you're like oh [ __ ] my life is [ __ ]
i'm on the ground yes i'm on the boat
bus
of a chinatown bus on the rocks please
all right that's a great great drink
this is perfect i love that you're
mixing it up you're getting creative
it's great nailed it also when i like
smoke a weird drawing called spear
airlines you know
there you go i got a crazy story for you
please i was in uh columbus over the
weekend i just kind of just well enough
from you know i just got over covered
yeah just well enough to uh this is my
first drink oh hey by the way yeah good
to have you back it's good to be back
but
um you know i'm in columbus ohio with
gary veda we had a great weekend the
crowd's a great great club great
columbus funny bone great great crowds
yeah and uh we're leaving gary starts to
feel crummy not covered he just you know
already had it but he had a cold and
we're coming back
sunday morning early flight not a lot of
options was like it was like a 10 am not
brutal but like early when you worked
before yeah we get there we're in the
clear pre-check line we're you know
we're both pros from the road
we there's a woman in front of us
the worst human being i've ever uh oh
just one of those people that you like
she's a problem she's she's an angry
white woman yep it's the she fits the
stereotype
big loud louis vuitton bag two kids
yelling at the woman
yelling at her and it's the clear line
she goes miss you're so bad at your job
she starts going she goes you're so and
it's like the morning shift so i'm like
pretty angry for this woman yeah and she
goes you're so bad at your job how are
you so bad how are you so bad like whoa
like goes on for like at least two
minutes
like non-stop shoes what's your name oh
what's your name i'm gonna complain
about it and the woman is like carmen my
name and she just keeps hammering her to
the point where finally veto and i are
looking at each other like is this for
she got two kids with her
probably 12 years older so they could
tell they're humiliated yeah and this
and and you can also tell she does this
a lot just one of those people
and and she she didn't even know you
know it's the thing we have to line up
your eyes yeah yeah to get unclear and
she didn't know what she was doing but
she's yelling at this woman geez for at
least two two and a half minutes which
is a long time for someone to just be
berated totally so finally get to a
point where i go hey lady
enough oh
i love enough and she go she looks at me
she goes what i go i go stop talking to
her like that and she goes this doesn't
concern you i said it didn't now it does
yeah i said and everyone in the in the
whole in the whole area hates her yes
and and you know the ticket guy is
looking at her like she's complaining to
him this is what i interrupted she's
like what's
who do i complain to and and he could
you could tell he's rolling his eyes
like what do you want and i go i go
enough and she goes this doesn't
continue and now it concerns me and she
goes she goes security on me
i mean i go i don't work for you ladies
i don't like you
i'm like and they all hate you and then
and then peter goes this is hilarious
reader goes he goes this isn't the movie
of your life you're a nobody whoa
wiener coming in with the assist rita
calls her a nobody and then she goes she
panic she goes you're short and gary
goes you should see me without my shirt
on i'm like oh
he kind of blew it though he kind of
blew it we had it we had her on the
ropes and you there's like when you
tagging the guy in wrestling and he's
like and he runs in and then immediately
gets like knocked out but uh and i was
just like i was like let gary and he's a
guard sorry sorry
and then i was like
and then i say i say
you know
she's still rattled though cause she's
not used to people talking back yes you
can tell
she needs it though she might have
wanted to blow you i mean i doubt a guy
said that to her in 10 years and well
maybe when he did he finally left
because he seemed like a single mom
situation right but uh you know finally
we go we fly through she's getting the
full body pat down and i get a look from
the ticket guy like a nod like thank you
random search yeah random sir [ __ ] her
but gary and i were energized after yeah
you got that right we left and we were
like that was like a second cup of
coffee it's like batman and robin you
two in there you're fighting crime
you're awesome craig i mean you see
those videos and i you know your
instinct goes to go for your phone and
shame this person but i'm glad we just
did it
you karen the karen i karen the karen
hell yeah
i did wow karen and sharon
all right
but that reminds me one time i was at
shoni's with my dad remember shony's did
you know shony's it might be a regional
thing i've heard of it but i've never i
don't know what it is it's like a ruby
tuesday kind of [ __ ] box family
yeah i had a salad bar but the pink and
the salt here i'm licking this like at
the vagina oh yeah
let me get my nose in here real quick
what happened
so i must have been seven or eight years
old i'm out with my dad whenever my dad
had no when my mom was on around he
would just take us out to dinner he's
like i don't want to cook so we'd go to
shonies i love shonies and
this lady is like hitting her kid the
kid is screaming he's like a
two-year-old and she's like shut up and
she's like hitting him and the whole
restaurant's like oh my god this is
brutal and my dad stands up and i'm like
oh geez here we go my dad's a nut and he
goes lady if you hit that kid again i'm
calling social services and the whole
restaurant you could hear a pin drop and
she goes [ __ ] sit down and he goes hit
him again
and even the kid was like
like a two-year-old he's in a diaper and
i was like oh my god it's like a mexican
standoff and she's like i don't tell me
how to raise my kid he's like do it
again and then we paid the bill and left
and everybody went
that's the only time these people by the
way these terrible parents the only time
they are mad is when someone else tells
you they're a shitty parent because they
know they are right that's the only time
they're actually upset yeah it's it's
very similar to a heckler you know when
they get thrown out they're like oh what
was i didn't do anything i was laughing
like no you have you're so clueless you
have no idea that the whole room hates
you he took away
your dad took away her power because
that kid never looked at it the same way
oh
yeah right after that she was like he's
like yeah well you're lucky that guy's
not here he [ __ ] lay into you right
right he hit it with a nice lady yes who
out throughout that white male privilege
well it sucked for us because now the
kid lived with us for a year
that's the sitcom
that's the show yeah see my dad has a
little karen in him so like i've seen
him chew people out before and i'm like
older people do sometimes have it yeah
exactly because they're used to like
customers always write uh i'm paying you
so you have to act a certain way they i
think they have a little that old-school
mentality but hitting the airline
employee it's like dude
okay we've we've all been the victim of
people who treat us like [ __ ] at the
airport we've all but like when it's not
warranted you can't do that [ __ ] no no
i've definitely i remember i missed i
this was like early in my career i was
just trying to save money and i did a
website called cheapo air oh i know
cheapo yeah it was like the alternative
to kayak it was or expedia whatever it
was if you were trying to get a deal and
it's like if you're a gambling man which
we were oh yeah you would do um you get
frontier maybe a spirit yeah
you would get connect flights sometimes
on different airlines yeah so this is
the game you're playing you're like all
right i got a flight for 150 but uh it's
it's frontier two spirit yeah i gotta i
gotta so here's what happens when he's
to gonorrhea you know it's two horrible
things but when you but when you get
like you miss the flight neither airline
is accountable right that's the problem
it's like if you miss a delta connection
they're like we'll get you on the next
one sure you missed two they're like go
[ __ ] you're an idiot
you're a cheap idiot i know and every
time you get on that plane you're like
it wasn't worth it the seats are wicker
you know there's like cigarette butts in
the handle bar and they have the armrest
and there's like a
cage of chickens next to you you know
like what am i doing i should have just
paid the forty dollars extra and got a
normal flight the flight attendant has
an s m whip what the hell
yeah no we i remember i missed the
flight i was so upset i had to buy i
think a 583 dollar ticket to a festival
and remember i told the guy what
happened by the way cheapo air when you
say that you do you won't admit that's
the airline right it's the only website
that sounds like an insult
you're a cheapo you're an idiot
so i told the guy i was like oh well one
of you guys has to be accountable and
you go he just he's i remember the guy
just laughed in my face he was like
you're you're a fool
he was mocking me and i remember i go
[ __ ] you i just lost it and of course i
divided it and then i moved over and
this woman saw she was like come over
here and she was like so but i still
have to buy the ticket that'd be great
if you were like [ __ ] you and some
ladies like that's enough
you crossed the line
no he was mocking me for like 10 minutes
when i was panicking i'm like that you
can't but like if someone's just doing
their [ __ ] job yeah yeah it's crazy
told me he was in vancouver recently and
he missed they were for whatever reason
just kicked him off the connect flight
and he just missed it so we got home
instead of like 2 p.m to get home at
midnight oh and the person and stop is
like yeah i had a meltdown on the person
oh but they had no reason to kick him
off the flight no yeah that's crazy when
they do that sometimes it's warranted
sometimes and they just give you that
[ __ ] eating grin with their vest and
their wings behind the desk so i get it
your blood's boiling
so if we're talking flights i gotta lay
a whopper on you
all right so i was going to cincinnati
on friday
yeah
not a great flight situation with
cincinnati but i found a two o'clock
that lands at four o'clock two hour
flight so risky i'm doing one of those
in a week and i'm nervous everybody's
like it's a little late i'm like ah i
get there you know four o'clock the
show's at seven i got three hours you
know and it's risky it's risky i get
there and they go right when you get
through security get your phone back ah
delayed [ __ ] delayed an hour all right
so now i'm getting there at five shows
at seven all right
delayed again i'm getting there at six
and now we're calling the club and doing
the whole like okay you're gonna have to
land and come straight here with your
bags and you're like all right that
sucks but i'll make it work
boom hey now that's delayed again you're
gonna miss the first show but we'll
we'll get you to second show you know
whatever it is they'll stretch and
eventually the anxiety the anxiety but
the glimmer of hope the silver lining
the ray of sunshine
i took your advice i got the american
express card
i'm in the lounge yes nice i didn't even
want to get the flight i had the feet up
i had a hot cocoa i had a beer i had a
buffet going on i had a dessert buffet i
mean i was i was the [ __ ] in there i
always get that cookie that caramel
cookie oh the cookie i'm dipping in the
coffee it was great i had a face mask on
and uh woody kiwis on my eyes or
whatever i mean i was milking that place
and they kept being like delayed again
delayed again i was like great [ __ ] it
who cares i was looking up at the wall
like push it back so then eventually it
was like 11 o'clock so i landed at one
but that lounge i mean it saved me
but
here's the problem i missed both shows
friday which is always a [ __ ] i don't
know if that's ever happened to me oh
that's the worst i miss one i don't
think i missed two is brutal two is bad
because you lose the money and then i
was i had all my merch there so you lose
the merch sale so the whole thing sucks
but either way i got there finally at
two in the morning now everybody on the
plane is cranky because they weren't in
the lounge
so they're all just been waiting in the
airport pissed off yeah
so i watched a big
fight
not fistfight but so this lady sitting
next to me she's probably a 60 year old
blonde woman she's in the aisle the
plane finally lands it's one in the
morning everybody's annoyed she gets her
bag down
and then she goes to grab mine to be
nice and she's pulling him down i got a
fat bag so she's trying to get it out
i'm like man my god it's heavy don't
worry about it she's like no i'll get it
i'll get it now there's a lady behind
her with two kids and she's like my kids
have seizures you're bringing other
people's bags down i gotta get off this
flight she's like man the door's not
even open like what's the difference let
me bring this guy's bag down she's like
[ __ ] you don't talk back to me so now
they're fighting you yeah it got ugly
and there's two kids behind her it's
like mike you've got a big louis vuitton
bag it's the same woman
well this one was a little different and
she's just like [ __ ] you and the other
one what's your problem so now the door
opens and the blonde lady is just like
getting out of there she's like this
lady's a little volatile i'm getting off
this plane so then
the uh lady with two kids is like
chasing her and she's got her two kids
in tow so it's slowing her down but
she's like [ __ ] you
yelling in the airport now i'm like
keeping up with these people because i
want to watch and she's like i got two
kids with seizures [ __ ] you [ __ ] this
is why uh we don't like blo we don't
like white people because you people
like you and the blonde lady's like what
the [ __ ] is going on here you started
this with a kind gesture i know no good
deed so i'm just like whoa and i'm
getting too close to the crazy list this
is at 11 or so when you're about one in
the morning oh my god so there's people
in the airport sleeping and looking up
like what the [ __ ] guys are on their
video games like what's happening and
you don't want to get too close because
then now you're in the you're in the
wake you know and she'd be like what are
you looking at you know that whole thing
so eventually she chased her out there
and i i had to go to baggage claim but
uh pretty wild i mean the tensions are
high at these days at the airport kids
have seizures is a weird complaint i
think she's giving these kids seizures
about these uh these outbursts yeah what
the hell i don't get what does that mean
so they can just have a seizure it's
like yeah but what's
three more minutes exactly you just want
to take these people and hug them like
what's really going on what's the
problem what do you need
should i [ __ ] yeah what is it will that
help you want a cookie do you want a
massage what is the deal should have
bought some cookies from that lounge
dude
hand out some cookies
in a good mood yeah that would help
so you landed at 1am and you made up the
shows or no i made up we added one on
sunday but then it's like a mix of
people did it sell out it did but they
were like i did a q a at the end and
every question was like where the [ __ ]
were you it's one of those things where
you get in trouble i'm like the flight
was yeah it's not a fun day for you it
happened to veto on thursday when we
were in columbus he had to
he was going to do the thursday
and headline that and open for me friday
saturday and he lost his whole day at
the airport yeah same [ __ ] 11 a.m flight
he's there until 7 00 p.m it got
cancelled but is he in the lounge yes
okay that helps that helps you should
see him with his shirt off
one of the worst comebacks i've never i
love gary he is shredded i'll give him
that he's ripped but you can't we had
her on the ropes yeah he can't it's
funny how you can make fun of a man's
appearance but if you make fun of a
woman's appearance it's like times 10.
oh we could have exactly we were we
really were holding back yeah because
your short is like a that's a dig that's
you know you feel like you're fat gary
is a bad about how you can he's a lot of
material and how you can say a guy sure
but yeah yeah it's
hidden right into his i'm like gary you
got so many bits about this you could
have hit it with one of those weave that
into your act get people in the
whole airport on board right he
shouldn't cause the shirt off i don't
even know what that means like what are
you gonna fight her i have seen him with
a shirt off and i will say he he's very
strong
he looks very good but the fact that
we're talking about this it it was too
out of nowhere
yeah well i'm girthy downtown
what else are you gonna say
he should have been like yeah i'm sure
but i can i'm tall enough to see that
you're a [ __ ] something like that this
is a real jerk store moment
i know i know
but yeah the airport man it's uh
it's a tough sledding these days
it's it's uh anarchy out there anarchy
man but you had a good weekend otherwise
great weekend cincinnati's cool went to
go bananas to get to drink with the
locals i had a fun time oh that's a far
isn't it it's about 20 minutes you know
but that's it but the funny bone is in
liberty it's in the mall so i had to get
out yeah the staff there's great they're
it's a great great really well-run club
but it is in the middle of nowhere it is
yeah it's in the burb it's big time
it's like a 45 minute drive from the
airport just to get there
brutal that was my opener hey it's going
to be in almost cincinnati i know i said
something like that too or something
along the lines of like uh where the
[ __ ] are we yeah
what is this yeah you're one of those
fake towns where they have a little
square you have grass and then they have
a sephora an apple store
chipotle it's all the same [ __ ] funny
you get to these these mall areas like
you know gary and i were at a funny bone
too we're in columbus and
the second you get there you're like
this is kind of great we have like all
these stores you can just walk to and
literally within 15 minutes we're like
get me the [ __ ] out of here yes small
suck
i hate them i i have nothing like
how long can you spend in a lids exactly
you walk in the lids you're like i can
get a hat you're like i don't want a
[ __ ] hat i don't need a hat i don't
need this it's all [ __ ] i don't need i'm
like walking around pier one like oh
maybe i will buy this buzz like what the
[ __ ] am i doing i don't need any of this
stuff gary's like they have cool jackets
and cotton on i'm like all right you
know like i'm going like this i'm like
this [ __ ] sucks yeah let's check out
the rei why i have a coat we went to a
cheesecake factory and uh i like a
cheesecake face that's the best change
they're solid yeah but it's this [ __ ]
mall so of course we go there and we're
only there friday saturday it's got to
be
a 40-minute wait you get a table oh yeah
and it's like saturday morning so it's
must be like not nine-to-one kid ratio
yeah to adult and i'm just like this is
killing me they're just running around
us gary and i still don't feel 100 we're
[ __ ] losing our mind yeah i've never
been more pro choice in my life
that's not true i was on that flight
from orlando that one too but you're the
opposite of jared fogle you see kids
you hate them you're like oh this sucks
vogel gets in there he's like this is
great and i'll never try to sell you on
subway either sandwiches too they're
terrible
yeah so i'm with you though the kids are
rough but you get back to new york and
they're like some lady was pushed on the
track she's like all right we're back
baby back it's so boring over there it
is funny when you think the city is
losing its edge and then i was i was
like mad you just you go every block
it's like starbucks walgreens rite aid
and then and then i i was out late at
night and there was a guy just in clown
makeup on a scooter and i was like hell
yeah this city's still got an edge yeah
no one's [ __ ] with that clown guy i
know i catch myself in in liberty ohio
i'm watching videos of the the homeless
guy who put [ __ ] in the woman's face and
i'm like jerking off to that oh i'm so
bored out here
like yeah rub it in unlike that poop
this city is going down the toilet am i
right no that's uh
that is really what a story oh yeah that
the the poops mirror he was released and
arrested again
what yeah that's actually one of the
stories we're supposed to talk about
today oh yeah bring up some stories
there it is
you don't want to hear that guy releases
ever that's not a good sign no
that says you know what it's like it's
like in remember in the dark night when
when heath ledger's like this city
deserves a better class of criminal and
you're like oh this maybe this is the
criminal new york deserves right now
maybe this is what we get well senator
this quote he said don't let me out
again
what he said to the cops after he was
arrested
in washington heights self-storage
facility
for going berserk on a worker whoa and
then he said what am i going to do next
to shock the city
he's like a super villain he is he's
shitty riddler
shitty riddler schindler
adolf shitler yeah holy moly what a
psycho hitler's list
he's got a list he's working on
he's got a [ __ ] list
damn
yeah this city is uh they say they're
cracking down but who the hell knows
that's a that's a pretty horrible crime
yeah you walk in on someone taking a
[ __ ] you feel violated think about how
violated you feel someone smears their
own fecal matter
what's nuts is he realized he went viral
for this so he's like looking for the
next hit yeah they want attention he's
an influencer damn
sadly but there's it's it's weird that
there's viral for good and bad i mean
it's like it doesn't mean that oh wow oh
poor lady it's like
six in the morning just minding her
business
probably going to some [ __ ] job no pun
intended and then boom smash in the face
with a turd how do you get over this how
do you because you [ __ ] every day too
what you do is you're going dancing with
the stars next season
you try to turn into positive press the
smears look i know he smears she's not
doing that anymore he's trying to clean
up his image
yeah that is tough
yikes
geez oh wait i just had did you see
batman i haven't seen him yet i haven't
even i want to see it i want to see it i
want to see an imax but it's three and a
half hours or something crazy so long
i've heard our buddy ronan says it
stinks yeah and and he's such a hater
that i didn't but he's like no i love
the nolan ones i love the noble ones i
do too they're hard to follow yeah what
i mean
have you seen it yet no
beer jew
matt peters
damn wow we are disappointing white men
yeah it's breaking records at box office
although it's not doing as well as
spider-man did right didn't spider-man
kill it
i heard that was great
i don't know super superhero yeah people
love it i haven't seen any of the new
spider-mans but they're supposed to be
pretty good i i only have one spider-man
in my heart so toby toby yeah
the cartoon growing up was pretty damn
good that was good yeah it was funny it
had good
he was witty the batman cartoons were
fantastic batman beyond and stuff like
that mark hamill [ __ ] incredible joke
yeah
i never knew about that until like three
years ago that that was mark hamill the
whole time yep and call me a boomer but
i like the old pow bang
boom
some levity to it now it's like ah
i got diarrhea you know
too serious now some studio execs like
this poop smear guy's hot
pattinson you're out blue smear that's a
good name the poop's man
i think my girlfriend's getting one of
those
the poop smears guy's parents got killed
and now he reigns havoc on the city they
died of constipation
never been the same since this is the
dumbest episode we've done oh see look
at the colors the technical this it's so
sixties
i love this [ __ ] surprises batman it's
really exciting
soon very soon batman and i will be
battling right out of your tv sets and
onto your theater screens
yes classically trained actor yeah
sure in color opens a whole new world of
thrills
oh how cool is that i like that he's got
his [ __ ] eyebrows uh drawn up yeah
yeah he's like the chick at the airport
he went to a beauty parlor in crown
heights that batmobile is badass though
look at i got the bat copter adam west
[ __ ] rules look how cool the villains
are they look like comic books
that cat one was so hot yeah dude
what was her name julie newmar
the entire world
oh so cheesy look at the the dutch
angles
oh lee merriweather sorry there's two of
them you're right
when i get batman in my claws
ah i love it have you heard this one now
here's my theory
[Music]
now feel free to kick me the balls here
because you know i like to get grandiose
with my theories
i think
life was a little harder than you know
vietnam war is cooking race riots civil
civil rights yadda yadda those are cool
now
well hold on
but i think people worked hard jobs you
did labor you watch the news yeah all
right hold on
maybe the theory is
no no no no no no you're already you're
i want to stay from good prove me wrong
here but
everything back then even james bond was
a lot lighter sean connery is uh you
know making out with a hot lady on the
beach and then he has a gadget and he
punches the bad guy and everybody wins
now but now bond is [ __ ] sad and
tortured batman is tortured
but i think people have it easier now i
know we have the news and we have corona
and blm we still have some things
cooking
ukraine
but everybody's a graphic designer
everybody works from home everybody has
a an ipad and a laptop and i think
we gotta make problems now almost
whereas then you had problems so the the
shows were lighter now everything's dark
and
sad and evil
maybe because we have no we have less
struggle i think there's truth to that
because i i think post when all the
great film noirs came out was post-world
war two
right where people wanted that darkness
though right yes but then i also think
it just it's it moves in cycles
like
remember i think those i think the
batman movies the nolan one started with
a dark batman
right the other one before that was a
little sillier it was like
batman and robin and batman forever
which kind of sucked
up but then it kind of went back with
iron man which is like he's kind of
silly and
climbing and yeah he's like it's a more
fun superhero movie yes than bat
batman's dark yeah that's true parents
are dead but even bob kane i think we
talked about this even bob kane the
inventor of batman is like i don't like
batman now it's a bummer
i had a fun guy mm-hmm so
he's he created the [ __ ] thing
that's fair well i think also like
there's at some point in order to make
the serious run like it's course you
can't have it be like happy-go-lucky you
gotta read the whole time
so like what i'm thinking is like now
like we have like for example deadpool
is like our funny guy he's just [ __ ]
amazing by the way yeah he's great the
first one's great so what in like what
20 30 years are we gonna have
like the downfall the actual downfall of
deadpool where actually
even though his story is already like
chaotic yeah but what you're saying is
absolutely right because it's
they they only will remake the same [ __ ]
yeah they have to remake it differently
right yes like into the spider verse was
a great movie so these execs are so
uncreative they're like well this is a
proven commodity spider-man will do well
we don't we're not going to try a new
super or if they do won a new one it's
got to be a marvel one or a dc one gotta
have some existing ip yeah they won't
take a chance on it but like into the
spider verse was a great movie and that
was different yeah you know you see with
madonna material girl you know long
gloves stockings sexy and then it goes
to like
weird madonna then it goes like a techno
madonna then it's like kind of urban
madonna you gotta we all like madonna so
she's proven
so you gotta change it up madonna new
ass then she had an old ass then she got
another new ass there you go keep it
fresh you know i followed her at the
garden yeah you told me that's amazing
crazy great did you talk to her
i think i said good set and she went
not
much um but oh so i got to tell you i
went and saw sebastian van escalco on
monday at the garden how was that it was
[ __ ] great and i'm never i'm not like
a sebastian head i'm not one of these
guys who's obsessed with him i got
nothing against him i think he's a cool
guy but
i was never a sebastian guy
you know and i i got free tickets with
the same agent i went
south volcano
matteo lane rosebud great crew and we
all went and saw it and we got some free
drinks and open bar and food
and pat mcgann opened
sold out garden i'm talking i got to
walk in with everybody people are
speaking italian
it is like guido in there it's full
country and godfather too yeah
yeah exactly it was wild there it is and
uh oh my god what can you imagine
performing at that many people that
they're your people insane that's insane
by the way last time he did the
prudential in jersey which is like their
guard or the rangers play or the devils
rather the devils yeah and then
rangers play here he's doing barclays
tomorrow wow he sold them all out
so when he's uh taking that picture does
he
turn around to the crowd say everyone
turn your phones on your camera lights
on and face him towards me did he say
anything else well he he did his set it
was a great set seventh hour by the way
wow
all these people have heat and are hip
and are cool he's just writing material
and then performing it to his fans he's
i don't want to say he's under the radar
but like
you never hear about him as like in the
top five burr louie attel chappelle you
never hear about sebastian and i think
he i think it's kind of cool i respect
the fact that he's just like out there
working and he's like i don't need to be
not about the accolades it's about the
work right i agree
that's what i'm saying i think that's
cool about him yeah and so he did his
whole set i mean that's insane look at
that it was insane that is massive and
he he didn't said it was great he ended
on a big story big ending and then he
did a whole like it's so great we can
come back out this show is rescheduled
50 times and i'm glad we could all make
it work on a monday and he did a whole
act out like we gotta go see this
[ __ ] guy on a monday yeah you know
that was funny and then he goes wow we
do a thing where we get the phones out
do the light we'll all get photos it'll
be great and it was it was a nice moment
it's nice yeah
so i like stories like that
that's me as my aunt yeah yeah that's a
nice story
but it was cool to see i'm sitting next
to sal volcano matteo lane's in front of
everybody's
you know comics laughing i love it silly
stuff relatable stuff observational no
politics no you know divide the room
just fun
pro entertainer yes total pro shiny
jacket big movements
good good uh good angles it's hard to do
arenas is a political act i would think
a political comedian that would be tough
[Music]
hard to move tickets like that i know
because then it becomes dangerous for
your comedy because it's like if you
have that big an audience then you're
you're probably pandering
unless good point i can't it's hard to
think of a political comic that chapel
whether
i guess he does issues but he's not you
don't think it was like a jon stewart
type
but john stewart was never doing those
arena
you know he was doing a show but it's
hard to it's hard to be a political
comedian
because
part of being i think a good comedian is
them not always knowing your take i
agree and once you kind of align with
the party it becomes dangerous i think
for your comedy yeah
yeah cause then you gotta pander and
then
that's what i never got like if trump
does something stupid if trump shits his
pants i'm gonna make a joke about it if
biden shits his pants i'm gonna make a
joke about it my mom gets upset when i
do biden jokes yeah mommy's the
president yeah this is my job exactly
this is i'm gonna make biden joke i'm
gonna make trump jokes it doesn't make
sense to split it down the middle like
well i can't make fun of that it's it's
the left side or it's the right side
you're like well now you're you're
ruining your whole act this should be
the funniest thing yeah i won't make fun
of putin but uh that's a great guy
but uh i heard some model said uh i'm
i'm against putin and russia and she
she's missing yeah but that was yeah but
her boyfriend killed her it wasn't yeah
it wasn't that was a misleading headline
i saw that headline too and i was like
wait
that's a classic new york post headline
where they're like
what could have happened i'm like just
click just tell us in the headline yeah
don't make me read this whole [ __ ]
article
when it's clear that's what that's all
their stuff they're like person missing
in russia and they're like it was a
suicide
conference i think i might have to pull
out of this podcast because you're part
russian
all right
they're doing some of that [ __ ] now i
should be the one pulling out
then but there's people like he's a
russian singer we yeah we can't let him
perform here you're like what why are
you punishing him it's not yeah putin
doing the [ __ ] exactly
uh obviously protesting which is pretty
dangerous there sure uh do you want to
hear it my 23andme is not that it's i'm
all over eastern europe i'm i'm a
ashkenazi jew okay okay i like how
insecure i just got guys
yeah in yugoslavia you're a nazi though
i like that you think ashkenazi jew is
helping you
okay so putin is doing something
insanely
uh sinister
he's taking people and arresting him at
the anti-war protests and conscripting
them into the army
wow
that's such a [ __ ] psycho brilliant
sitcom
but wouldn't they have no incentive to
fight how about a gun to your back
saying go fight or we're going to put
you in jail or kill you yeah the guys
who gets your first invaded ukraine had
no incentive to fight either yeah they
were told you could see these uh
interviews online uh where they captured
russia the first russian soldiers to
invade ukraine they were like why the
[ __ ] are you doing this they're like
they told us we were just doing
exercises on the border whoa
and then they told us to walk in yeah we
signed up for a p90x class i don't know
why you're invading a country
it's called barry's boot camp
damn that's wild yeah the news is so i
was wondering why they're like stealing
like farmers are towing russian tanks
like ukrainian farmers or russian towing
russian tanks out
and they just captured a russian missile
system like some ukrainian farmer with a
tractor
wait you're russian
i'm i was born in ukraine and i'm
russian oh geez you're born there yeah
well you're you're like divided within
yourself i mean yeah do you have family
there still yeah that's crazy um are
they alive so yeah yeah all right but uh
did they evacuate uh
well i have some
i was born in the crimea so in 2014
that was a big problem you're russian
now then oh i've been russian yes
exactly
when i was born i was born ukrainian but
now i'm rushing against a real pain here
mark
this is a sketch venting the mark
all right mark is a terrible therapist
the guys point his heart out mark's like
pun
but like
what's it called like like you know how
how shitty is it that like they have
like the largest weapon systems in the
world
and some random ukrainian farmer just
drags it away with the tractor yeah yeah
he's dragged away a missile system
what's insane
it's ridiculous and why because [ __ ]
these people don't want to be there yeah
yeah correct i mean that is really
it says a lot when people are [ __ ]
scrappy and angry and this is everything
to them they're fighting for their
country these people don't want to even
be there fighting anyway
no they got a farm
that's crazy yeah it is crazy you see
the attitudes of people there and and
you you watch the news and people are
like yes we were displaced and it's just
me and my son
and i you know i lost my job but you
know we'll be okay and i'm like wow you
should see how much i complain
yeah like i would kill for your outlook
on life i know i know
see i need to get i need to get better
at that it's a reminder to be grateful
that's my wreck there you go we all do
the whole country needs a little vanilla
yeah we all do because you know
uh you ever do that here's another wreck
if you and i i might have done this on
the pop before we ever feeling like low
or angry and you like catch yourself and
you're like
playlist that's cheerful pick-me-up
music
yeah that's big
songs what's on your playlist ooh you
made me feel like dancing
that song from slap shot great song
great song i'm so excited pointer
sisters fun [ __ ]
[Music]
easy great jacket though
yeah it's a cool jacket can i sing it
you can sing it you know what mine is uh
ace freely i'm back
back in new york i always play that when
i land in new york and i'm like i am
back and then i'm like [ __ ] uber
i do like it's a good song it's a great
tune
yeah kiss is like another like like a
sebastian where i feel like they're kind
of underappreciated i agree they kind of
got like made fun of corny maybe because
gene simmons seems like he's nuts but uh
i mean they got some great songs oh yeah
oh yeah they rocked like i mean they
sold out arenas for years also uh alice
cooper's cameo in wayne's world is
[ __ ] amazing
so good milwaukee
that's such a brilliant move too these
alice cooper types were just like i'm
gonna write a song called
school's out for the summer
it'll be a hit it'll play every summer
in every school i'm huge you know it's
kind of like queen has a bunch of those
like we will rock you and uh all the
songs they play at baseball games yeah
brilliant you just get all the royalties
we might be drunk and sponsored by
better help online therapy relationships
take work a lot of us will drop anything
to go help someone we care about we'll
go out of our way to treat other people
well but how often do we give ourselves
the same treatment for me
working out or buying some new sneakers
is an investment in myself this month
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to take care of your most
important relationship the one you have
with yourself we're in therapy we go to
the same guy it's necessary clean out
the garbage your head has all these
horrible thoughts
splicing your childhood traumatic
experiences you're a wreck you're a mess
you need therapy get out the garbage
whether it's hitting the gym making time
for a haircut or even trying therapy
you're your greatest asset so invest
time and effort into yourself like you
do for other people tell them how better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
maybe you got a weird boil on your face
or something you're weird you know you
don't want to see that you're all said
yep it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours give
it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy we might be drunk is sponsored
by better help and listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash drunk
you got to do this it's it's therapy
very important take care of yourself
it's going to change your life here here
we might be drunk is thrilled to welcome
our new sponsor fanimal
i love live events i hate buying tickets
the hidden fees suck and coordinating
with your friends is the nightmare
they're garbage i always end up fronting
a bunch of money and chasing down my
friends to get reimbursed not me
personally because i'm very generous
if they flake i'm stuck with a whole
bill
and then i discovered fandible fandible
has tickets to everything there's no
fees the price you see is the price you
pay that's i mean that's pretty big yeah
not only those prices transparent but
they're almost always lower than
anywhere else i look and for any hot
ticket like coachella a laker game or
dave chappelle fanimal is always the
cheapest option nobody gives nobody goes
to live events anymore so why buy
tickets alone fanimal although if you do
come to a show alone there's nothing
wrong with that honestly i love that
someone tweeted me about that the other
day they're like i wanna is it weird my
friend's bail is it weird if i come
alone i said no dude enjoy yourself yeah
and you know what the guy made new
friends at the show they tweeted me
afterwards i sat with these guys and
they were tweeting me too so you end up
having a great time no matter what
um
fanimal's patent group purchase makes it
easy first you set a minimum size for
your group and you choose the number of
tickets you want to pay for yourself
then you invite friends when the minimum
size is met everyone gets charged and
receives their ticket if the minimum
size isn't reached in time nobody gets
charged you don't commit until your
friends you march tell them how mark i
called you march
march march normand tell them how to do
it oh yeah and family has amazing
customer service don't take my word for
it check out their hundreds of five star
reviews the next time you need tickets
go to fanimal.com and sign up with
code drunk
for 20
of credit
20 of credit towards your first purchase
we drink on this show check out fanimal
and experience more
support the show and get twenty dollars
off your first purchase with the code
drunk at
fanimal.com f-a-n-i-m-a-l
dot-com get on
i want to play this song so bad i know
it's a good song yeah it puts you in
such a good mood yeah i have a lot of
songs like that mr blue sky
electric light orchestra oh yeah a lot
of great uh you gotta have your mix of
feel-good songs
i'll tell you what the ukraine i bet
they're watching old batman and old
james bond
lebanese they need lebanese
so yeah they just got it it's through
the booth they're just beating up one of
the uh russian military guys pal
[Laughter]
yeah
what uh what about a peeve oh i got
people you know that the ukrainian is a
comic right i heard that of course yeah
zolensky was he did the voice for
paddington in their version
yeah he's a comic he uh i mean this
really is like
stand-ups in america are no longer to
refer themselves as brave
right that's over yeah we're brave if we
gain weight
if they go to war he did a one-man show
in a turtleneck he's so brave
really is he talking [ __ ] to putin as
he's invading i know right and not
leaving his office yeah um
[Laughter]
he also played a show where he became
the president right ukraine and then and
then he became the president his friends
were like his friends like you should
run for i'm sure right now he's like
[ __ ] these
friends why didn't you tell me to make a
second movie
i know we could have done a sequel i
didn't have to actually become president
yeah yeah but it was like they were
corrupt politicians right and he was
like oh i can oust them and he did
i didn't know that but you know that's
wild i think they're releasing that on
netflix now has been a big push to get
that more people to see it yeah really
but yeah it takes for a comic to get on
netflix exactly
yeah you gotta fight boot
that's the audition but back to what you
were saying about you got to be grateful
we got to soak up the good stuff
oh [ __ ] i lost my point oh
i had something just come up with a pun
damn it now it was something
what's your wreck my wreck
oh i don't know if i have a wreck all
right give me a pee my peeve i gotta
peeve and we gotta do the rest of the
news right we didn't oh yeah we didn't
get to the get out of here
i had this one you ever have the guy who
won't stop reading your texts on the
train or in public he's looking over
your shoulder looking over my shoulder
and i mean i've texted some funny stuff
and whatever you know with comics and
this guy's like
friends
stranger completely straight and i catch
him so i give him one of these like
you know and then i kind of slide back
in my seat and he's doing it again he
couldn't stop reading it damn he
couldn't put it down
yeah that's pretty annoying brutal
brutal just annoys me it feels
it feels violating so violating so many
of our peeves are on the subway i
realized because that's
my peeve that i was thinking is also i
was in the train today and i'm walking
up the steps and there's a guy just in
the middle of the steps standing on a
laptop wow
oh i'm sorry i didn't mean to interrupt
your home office yeah
right
oh a laptop that's bold it's it's insane
yeah all right i got another one how
about this guy the guy who asks you a
question and then answers it while
you're answering it you know you go he
goes uh what are you drinking i'm like
i'm having a salty and he's like salty
dog like yeah yeah yeah i was gonna get
to it just let me get to it how
impatient are you i know you did like
five times like uh you seen good movies
lately i'm like uh i'm looking forward
to seeing
batman batman i'm like yeah what is this
family feud this isn't fast money just
let me answer it you [ __ ] win lately
your mom ah [ __ ] you gotta get it back
that way yeah you didn't see that coming
yeah yeah threw a curveball your way ah
piece of [ __ ] yeah so that that's who
whose joke was that where he's like uh
you know what i hate when people are
like uh
you know what i hate potatoes like you
gotta give me a second again uh mitch
hedberg yes yes yes brilliant colin
clinton at that brilliant joke where
he's like uh some guy's like all right i
gotta go do my laundry then i gotta take
the kids to school and he's like oh
sorry i'm just thinking out loud and
quinn's like yeah that's called talker
thinking out loud
it's a good name for a special think it
out loud yeah that's true i had i have
another good wreck uh please it's
another shout out to our boy ron
hirschberg it's a classic i don't know i
never read it he told me to read in cold
blood the capote book yeah it's insane
really one of the best written books
i've ever read in my life it's like it's
so well written that you're like holy
[ __ ]
non-fiction right it's about a murder
yeah yeah it's a real story they
invented a new genre
through crime yeah but it was called
something else it's called like it mixes
prose with
uh non-fiction it's written like a story
almost yeah yeah it's incredible
interesting and it's like man it's
it gives you like so many
waves of feelings where these people are
despicable these murderers but also
you're like man some one of them had a
really horrible life but still [ __ ] him
yeah like kind of up and down and the
way it's written
there's that famous line in it where he
goes
you know he kills a guy and he goes
he just casually says you know i thought
he was a nice man you know i thought he
was a a really soft-spoken nice man up
until the moment i slit his throat
says it like very calmly and you're like
you're [ __ ] crazy whoa did you see
capote i did but i i must see it again i
gotta watch it again now that i read the
book because i i wasn't it was one i
think i had a few drinks and i was like
this is good but i and i think i made it
like halfway through and fell asleep
like i got to do a whole it is one of
those it is one of those it's slow it's
a hard one when you had a few in you
right right there's real drama in it
though there's real drama in it though
yeah no i mean and he's he was the best
actor yeah
kelvin keener man oh i love keener great
great movie but i i i i could tell it
was a good movie and i and i should have
gone back to it yeah yeah i remember
seeing it too and i don't really
remember it but i was in and out but i
remember thinking the guy is nailing it
yeah he was such a good capote what uh
any racks
damn i've been watching you watching
severance i i gotta watch it yeah ben
stiller directed it right
i heard it's really slow though it's
slow but it's shot beautifully it's got
a great look great aesthetic and adam
scott is good but it's
it's uh
it's a churner you know you got to
really sit sit with it because it's one
of those it just puts you right in the
middle of it and then you're kind of
trying to piece it out over the show
um so i did the first two episodes and
it's coming together slowly but it's
it's heavy it's very malkovichy he's in
it isn't he is he oh maybe not i didn't
see him but i'm only two in
oh maybe you know what i'm thinking of
someone else no i uh yeah i do want to
watch it uh it's eerie it's torturo's in
it he's great yeah
he's a good guy good com i have a good
comic good actor yeah um
i've been watching like i watched that i
watched like the first two episodes of
that bad vegan thing on netflix
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] yes i got two
episodes in i was like this is the same
thing over and over
it was repetitive and not well made
and uh make it one episode make it one
episode they won't do it too much too
much of this [ __ ] making a murderer
could have been three episodes we don't
i know
like
it's it's why i just want to watch a
classic movie yeah even when a movie is
slow you're like at least they did it
they got it
certain shows like i love succession
there's some shows like that but
i'm watching these docs and i'm like get
to it i know i know we got it we don't
need this much
exhibition
is that the worst expository exposition
yeah we don't need as much exposition or
well i don't know if that's the right
word well they have to tell you the back
story yeah yeah i guess that is x yeah
it's too much it's uh
dude and they just it's the same [ __ ]
over and over again and and then i was
like let me just look up what happens
i'm like that's it that's it exactly
they got a milk they milk they milk yeah
ford exposition there you go
yeah that's too much what other news is
there i got a news oh baby
west side sorry question mark
the academy is facing harsh criticism
after west side story
lead rachel zegler
revealed she wasn't invited to the
oscars
oh
i'm staying home tonight i don't know if
we're gonna get sued
that's crazy
wow i heard the movie's great i haven't
i haven't actually it's beautiful i saw
a frame someone posted it it was like a
two and a half minute frame and it was
like one of the most beautifully shot
spielberg really is incredible
incredible
he he's so mainstream that he gets i
think he gets knocked for that but he's
great it's like sebastian he's
mainstream somebody's like ah
but spielberg is killed incredible
what uh indiana jones so many classics i
i want to see i should watch it it's on
hbo i think yeah and this was like her
big break oh look just the scene i love
it this is
[Music]
who is that guy that's that's his cousin
that's him puerto rican
is that okay
do you see him at dinner and have you
ever really i don't know family dinner
he's talked about i've seen him we've
hung out a couple days he's a really
nice guy i don't talk to that i don't
talk to bob really
so
what are you gonna do this movie was
i've seen this move the original like
800 times i love that movie
and it looks this looks even it looks
gorgeous it looks
i'm gonna watch this this weekend yeah
me too
wow the lyrics are killer too it's
incredible is it a hammerstein yeah one
of those
yeah they just did a like a cbs segment
on sunday in the park with george and it
was the other guy he wrote it with and
then it was like uh what's your name
bernadette peters and the other guy who
is you know you know what i'm talking
about the famous broadway actor uh oh
the redheaded lady yeah i was burning up
peter's but there's a guy too
what's his name just look up somebody in
the park with mandy patinkin ah
particularly but yeah some great songs
in that too but you know uh he was like
28 when he wrote west side story
unbelievable [ __ ] makes you feel like
[ __ ] officer krupke is incredible
great lyrics uh when you're a jet you're
a jet all the way from your first
cigarette to your last dying day you're
never alone you're always not protected
so good that'd be great if you're just
saying the whole song right
i would have listened oh yeah that's how
good the music is it's great tonight
tonight it's incredible the romantic
parts are boring but yeah yeah no but
the killing hell yeah yeah no uh also oh
you know what i watch belfast is really
good
i liked it
i haven't seen it i'm down it's a good
movie okay what what happens in that
it's it's about the the love story no
it's a coming-of-age story oh okay
in belfast it's good it's a good movie
that's the name of the jared fogle book
coming of age
oh epstein there you go perfect i need a
new pedo
huey lewis's uh lost album
uh yeah i saw there was a headline that
said epstein's uh pedophile island on
sale for 125 million i was like maybe
change the name
maybe you'll get even more than 125
million sounds like a reality show yeah
pedophile island yeah coming on after
fuckboy island
it's like how they do that in real
estate they're like it's proc prospect
park east
now that's [ __ ] crown heights shut up
what other what other news we got one
here the nose nose
it says bella's mother bella hadid i
guess yolanda allowed her 14 year old
daughter to get a nose job
is that too young for cosmetic surgery
oh i mean i know you're trying to sneak
this into a trans debate right now
uh
no i mean i think if you're a kid do
whatever you want but you know if your
parents are okay with it right but at
the same time
uh
sometimes the thing that you don't like
about yourself as a kid is gonna be i
mean what if owen wilson got a nose job
i mean that's like you know you know
like sometimes it's the thing that
you're known for this and it's like
like
it's true i hate my eyebrows but people
like recognize my or the fact that
matt's a pedophile
you never know what people are gonna
like about you that's true that's true
when i was a kid i had big curly hair
and i got made fun of and uh now i'm i'm
fine with having curly hair you know it
it's you could also accept things about
yourself 14 is pretty young i think you
should absolutely young you should allow
your body to fully grow before you make
these decisions because like what if her
nose keeps growing after 14. right
another one i almost got a penile
implant
because it's you know it's too big it's
too big yeah what uh
yeah what is too young 14 is pretty
young too young i think you're you're
still in high school you're a freshman
in high school it's too much you're yeah
you're barely in high school yeah that's
young that's crazy crazy
you could get hotter like a lot of
people grow into their looks that's a
hilarious thing for a parent to say look
you might not always be an uggo we don't
know that yeah you might change you know
your body is changing i don't know who
is she bella hadid yeah oh hold on big
model i know she's famous but what is
she famous she's a model she was married
to
someone until very recently and they go
well she her dad was a big mogul of some
kind and like she was married to one of
the guys in one direction and they
recently uh harry styles no the uh
oh i can't i don't know that one don't
act like you don't know man i do we all
know you know all about one direction oh
my jared fogle
yeah she's good looking but now she's
saying hey uh what if i had kept the
nose maybe i'd be even better or
whatever so you can't take it back
oh i'm sorry she dated the weekend her
sister married the other guy the weeknd
yeah oh he's good yeah i like him
yeah what uh what else what are the news
on standby snooze you lose yeah um
brittany griner is that hypocrite she's
in jail
yeah
yeah she's detained right she was
detained at moscow airport for drug
charges hash oil yeah that's strange
you know what happens with these wnba
players is they they play overseas
because they get paid so little in
america and you gotta buy your drugs
there so
uh
so she makes like four times what she
makes in the wnba interesting in russia
but then i'm sure she might guess i
don't know this story enough but my
guess like
if you're if you have hash oil you're
probably smoking every player smokes
not every player but a lot your
inflammation maybe you're doing that to
like relax your joints or something
or maybe just [ __ ] or chilling but
either way it's like some midnight
express [ __ ] totally and uh
and i i read that her family was like
they don't want this to be politicized
or something but also
because it is it's clearly being
politicized but she's considered i don't
know like top three best female players
ever is she the one that dunks
i think she's like six nine i think
she's dumb yeah yeah
yeah wow that's wild it's crazy also
it's like it's kind of [ __ ] up that
it's such a big story the lia thomas
thing is such a big story people are so
angry it's like you're angry about that
but not about brittany do you actually
give a [ __ ] about women's sports oh
cause this person's in she's detained
yeah somebody had an interesting take on
the leah thomas thing they were like i
know a lot of people are up in arms but
i never knew anything about women's
swimming and now i know a lot about it
so it's like bringing light uh attention
to it which is interesting i think the
truth is the other way that uh people
don't really give a [ __ ] about it and
was they i have a bit about it
i think i think i ran about i might have
a random oh yeah yeah sorry go ahead
where i say i was talking to a guy and
he was like uh
he said uh
you know this is there should be an
asterisk on those wins and i said i
called [ __ ] he goes exactly it's
like no that you care about women's oh
you care about women swimming you don't
give a [ __ ] and the bit was basically
like uh i've never heard you talk about
it you've never shown me that you give a
[ __ ] and then he was like what if i have
a daughter who becomes a competitive
swimmer and i was like you won't no
[Laughter]
you're 55 and you're a roommate all
right if you have a kid i have a feeling
it's not gonna be a winner yeah you know
and in that case if it is you know but
it is it's one of the things that annoys
me just because it's like this is the
issue you this is the one-ish time you
give a [ __ ] about the issue right right
you know what it feels like and feel
free to kick me in the balls here i got
another theory
it batman in the 60s
well it feels like
i think this kind of went down in the
40s with the black players
you know they're like hey oh can i get
another one
thank you sir
this could be a funny bit okay in the in
the 40s the black guys started playing
integrating with the white players and
they were kind of i'm sure they were
saying the same thing like we'll never
win again they're they're they keep
beating us they're mute this is the bit
the score okay maybe i got something
here i would take out the mutants but uh
well that's what they said
but there's a good premise right now ah
yeah like hey these guys
it's all dick
will never win again as a funny line
yeah it's unnatural
they should stick with their own people
it's the same argument oh yeah they're
saying they should make a class just for
trans athletes mega the negro leagues
negro leagues there you go well i guess
they already had you have to admit but
it's like yeah it is as you said
bringing more attention and it's like if
you're gonna watch it don't you want to
watch it now
of course that was a good point yeah but
it's spicy now but the brittany grinder
[ __ ] is so crazy to me because it's like
all right
here's here's what we need to do with
this it's you make air force one but
with a six foot nine black lesbian
as the lead she's beating the [ __ ] out
of putin in the movie that's the movie
what is that let's talk about a place
that doesn't understand like our culture
in that way right but it still pays them
more
yeah i mean it's pretty crazy
i'm actually surprised because it's you
know russians are always competing with
us you know space travel all these
sports and [ __ ] so i'm shocked that they
want our players over there to show them
up
maybe they just don't have a female
basketball team but i assume they would
rush must yeah it's some yeah it's some
i don't know the specifics are we just
that good over here the american players
are really good yeah i mean america i
think america is just the best at
basketball yeah i mean they're great
foreign players well don't we get blown
out in the
olympics we won the last one we had
durant dude yeah they're not they're not
beating the usa when kevin durant is
playing right we we didn't look amazing
but we we still won yeah kd is
unstoppable
but there are great foreign players now
yeah
there you go
um
all right what what else what are the
news yeah you got any i got another one
there yeah
let's see
uh 911 tribute museums closing oh what
the smaller of two museums built to
honor the victims of september 11th
attacks
with businesses down more than 80
percent due to the coronavirus pandemic
the institution simply couldn't survive
so it's closing
whoa they couldn't survive so now now
the cashiers call themselves survivors
i guess they forgot
yeah never forget that's crazy uh
so would there still one that's open
though i guess it says one of two
yeah i mean how many do we need that's
true i mean how many museums i mean yeah
yeah two buildings wow that's crazy i
mean i went but i you know you don't go
more than once i never won right don't
get a lot of repeat customers exactly
yeah you got it
yeah all they need is a uh mural a
statue and they got that pond down there
that fountain for yeah remember
reflecting reflecting pool yeah
so
what else do we need we need a gift shop
you know what what's in the gift shop
what do people buy i don't know
i got a button that says there were no
jews in the building so i don't know
but it was 50 obviously going at a
business sale
what the hell
that's crazy um i have another story
it's not here but uh elon musk
threatened or challenged putin to a fist
fight
for the rights of ukraine that's
adorable winner takes ukraine that's fun
yeah
how great that's like it's that's fun
can he can he fight musk i don't know
putin's kind of old but he does know
he's kgb
i still feel like putin would kick his
ass yeah
it'd be a big turnout i mean [ __ ] logan
paul
that's not a show i mean the numbers
logan paul would kick his ass
oh yeah oh yeah no doubt about it but
what about
damn musk i didn't i didn't know he
could fight
yeah you know like he's got the best
trainer obviously he's probably gonna
you know be ready yeah that trainer
might be blowing up his ego a little too
much try probably you're paying him what
600 a session with that kind of money
oh yeah you got him
don't worry
he's a judo master but you got him he's
over the hill just you know like
yeah he's an accord putin's got a bad
back i think he's like ah god there's a
lot of wear and tear
well there you go yeah but he also he
has been a judo master for the last like
20 years like he's like he's scary he's
killing his [ __ ] like he's a scary guy
black belt was recently revoked though
yeah yeah he's been out of everything
yeah the jiu jitsu uh society whatever
said we're taking back your black belt
because of this ukraine business ah so
he's not a black belt anymore uh-oh but
he's got the belt
i don't know that's a little that's a
little tough i think he's going to be
okay with it i mean he's he's sleeping
in a 1.7 billion compound uh is that
right yeah so i i think he'll be okay
with losing a piece of uh
cotton
damn did you do did you ever do a
martial arts not really did you i did
judo for like a year are you good no i
got beat up too many times i had to
leave so
i think i got to like yellow belt or
orange belt dude can you fight it all
uh
i can hang in i'm like cool and luke
i'll get beat up but it's so long that
the guy's like all right we're just
there sam i just hope
like that episode where homer just gets
punched in the face yeah
exactly just hope they get tired yeah i
can hang in but i'm not you know i think
what we just revealed is mark and i
drink
we can't fight yeah but we will not feel
the pain until the morning
right yeah
there was a fight i don't know it's a
ufc fight with sean o'malley where he's
like this great fighter and he's beating
the [ __ ] out of this one guy but the guy
wouldn't go down so the ref was like i
don't know what to do here and he's just
punching with the face the guy's face is
mangled bloody pulp
and they just had to call it like ah we
got to stop and he was like i'm so good
he was like wow i just can't let you do
this to your face that's pretty badass
it was pretty badass and the guy became
famous just from that fight even though
he didn't win that cool hand luke scene
is so cool i mean watching that growing
up was like hell yeah insane that big
guy who beat the [ __ ] out of him i
forgot the name of that actor but he's
from naked god that guy's great uh
kennedy yeah that's kennedy sponge
kennedy yeah
cool
this podcast because of us it always
will turn into a movie talk but
[ __ ] paul newman dude
i think what hud blew him up i think
yeah hud is a great movie but and then
the hustler but like cool and luke is
like is he ever cooler than the best man
luke the best
yeah he's in the sting sting
it's a good it's a good heist movie yeah
yeah road prediction uh was the jury one
the verdict verdict that's his best
movie great movie that's i think do you
think so it's incredible he's not
powerful and like virile he's sort of
like he's pathetic pathetic and i can't
i can't make that my favorite film of
his
it's not the coolest movie but yeah it's
like the it's the grittiest it's the
best mammoth dude yeah that's great yeah
uh yeah i know queen luke is great and
so is uh
butch cassidy's pretty oh butch cass
that was a big one
it's not as it's not as good as
luke but it was big
uh by the way
we talked about ron on speaking of
movies we should say that his special is
recording on the 11th at the village
underground would this be out by then
yeah this is april
hershberg comedy seller matt's directing
it
he is one of the best stand-ups i mean
he is he really is killer uh
he's
he's a machine dude yeah such great
jokes and uh
guaranteed this will be a killer special
he's been in europe
uh running it oh yeah he's touring like
crazy he was already a good comic it's
good he's gonna finally put that hour
down and you guys get to go see it at
the seller the comedy so the village
underground two shows eight and ten
eight and 10 p.m
uh april 11th uh if i'm in town i'll be
there for sure yeah i'll pop into that
do you know who's oh it's like a monday
i think it's caitlin pelufo oh fun
perfect this is so good i know i can't
put it down
well done sir ukraine
so you got any bits yeah what do you
what do you got
bits bits i forgot about bits i like it
all right i got too many i haven't seen
you in a while
uh here we go
okay
uh
oh that's not good
[ __ ] i had a big one
now i can't think of it is this anything
everybody mental illness is very popular
now it's like fashionable like hey i
have anxiety i'm depressed i'm ocd
but no one ever claims narcissism
that's the one mental disorder that no
one's like you know i'm a narcissist
like you don't see anybody say that like
oh yeah sorry i'm inconsiderate and
don't think about you but i'm a
narcissist well the thing is a
narcissist would never think about
themselves as having a negative
attribute ah
yeah right
it would be hard for a narcissist to
identify that himself as a great point
but it's also it shows that it's an
uncool one to have exactly because if if
you say like oh i've you know i'm
depressed like
depressed people get attention you're
the victim you're the victim right but
the narcissist makes you you're the
victim you're a victimizer yeah that's
that's a good see narcissism others
suffer yes great right yeah
smart that's the bit that's the meat of
it
it's the rise of dominant narcissism
yeah and narcissism i think it's up
like like everything others suffer who's
who is the first narcissist you think of
trump
yeah
other suffer right he's having a blast
yeah his wife
right his kid he's good right
yeah
but like you know but you know you see a
guy any politician is a narcissist sure
sure no doubt about it but like you see
a guy doing the locks five times like
what are you doing i'm ocd they're very
quick they're proud of you they're proud
of you did you just do rick glassman's
podcast
exactly but they'll never go oh sorry i
never call you back or i whatever you i
[ __ ] you over i'm a narcissist because
it's inconsiderate
yeah it's it's it's weird when your
disorder has the same
has the same attributes as someone who's
just a shitty friend right right yeah
but it would actually be growth to admit
it yeah but
narcissists don't really have growth
yeah yeah two up their own ass i'm a
narcissist i'm sorry i'm a narcissist
although
they don't apologize either yeah they
say i'm a narcissist you really have got
to get better friends
this is on you actually i have a bit
where i say yeah you've heard that yeah
i was in i'm in uh i say uh you know i
was dating girls always mad at me i told
my therapist goes well she picked you
she has to accept you and i was like
that's good stuff i'm gonna use it as a
weapon you know
and i come home [ __ ] face where were you
go this is a you problem
you gotta work this out but uh
different bit though but it's just uh
do you think i can use this yeah
absolutely yeah it's absolutely awesome
uh what do you got i have a lot of
ukraine jokes i have a lot of russia
jokes and i had one i was trying to work
on about how um
you know this is really the first
major war with uh camera phones
which really it's really a different war
like thank god we didn't have that for
other wars like you think like vietnam
you just look at footage like oh my god
turns out grandpa wasn't a hero this guy
this guy's a terrible person right you
know not only not only did he uh you
know turn in one of his own he you know
he impregnated three locals
something like uh
it's also harder to respect your your
war grandpa when he's like hey everybody
we're out here with the chopper uh
that's that's the chief over there he's
taking a [ __ ] you know we got opium over
here
we're having a good time you know the
selfie video
yeah we were yeah we were in it man we
were in it looks like a pretty nice uh
tent right
that's funny that's great the camera
phone is big yeah it's like the was the
war that serious if you're if you're on
snapchat yes yes yeah we're out here in
saigon like and comment uh subscribe
don't forget to subscribe
yeah the one guy is like yeah grandpa
yeah he he gave away our position
because he couldn't stay off tick tock
that's great that actually happened yeah
what yeah yeah um some guy in ukraine uh
was at the mall and said oh there's
tanks parked here on his tick tock maul
got blown up hours later
and now he's under arrest whoa
but he got a lot of followers yeah yeah
actually pretty good how many views and
that happened during like the actual in
2014 where they first took over crimea
there was a like i think it might have
been like a vice reporter someone who
followed a russian soldiers because they
wouldn't say that there was actual
russian soldiers in ukraine
they followed a russian soldiers like
facebook picks oh [ __ ] and follow them
all the way across the border and into
the correct meme like clearly they are
here like this crazy took pictures with
them with his pictures like align them
wow clearly this is happening like
you're an idiot for attacking yourself
technology and social media it's like
it's it's gonna change history books
it's so [ __ ] weird crazy [ __ ] up
history books because then you're going
to have 18 different history books with
like basically it's going to be like
hashtag this hashtag that yeah
those are the classes that you're taking
your attention spanish it's my
intentions man i feel everybody at bad
at [ __ ] but it's like even when i'm
reading a book i like to put it down for
me on my home and look at this let me
put on the tv first that was like a
basketball game on it i'll be reading a
book i'm like peeking over to basketball
score how much how much do we need i
know i know it's i'm in the shower with
a podcast playing and then i get out and
i i'm drying off with the tv and the
podcast still play it's sad it's
horrible and i have the news on all day
on top of it and i don't know why i
can't it's like part of my routine and i
can't break the habit and i should i
should put it off it's so
negative just coming at you so negative
there's nothing good on the news there's
nowhere that squirrel skiing you know
the good old days that'd be hilarious if
they're like we have some bad news in
ukraine but first uh charlie the
squirrel right here pull them up
oh great squirrel that that was
brightening people's lives dude i long
for the day of pizza rat
you're kidding exactly totally they're
like we have a breaking news bagel rat
the new rat is on the scene
this is what the note we're going to end
on the
oh no
what what i got a commercial here it is
oh he climbs on the ski he's adorable
he's just trying to live hell yeah he's
living his best life as they say he's
just is this animal abuse no
he's got a rope around his neck i'm
gonna go with yes wait he does oh yeah
remember robert joke about uh
the animals at sea world they're like
how does he pedal easy they nail his
legs to the [ __ ]
to the bike what do you think
i love how it's sponsored by gopro cuz
like from squirrel from humans in
squirrel suits to squirrels in [ __ ]
oh right well they don't have to pay the
squirrel
uh all right i found the joke i really
wanted to try but i could save it
because i i just kind of do it all right
all right so
doing this whole chunk about women are
sexier than men because men don't want
to be sexy we're only sexy on accident
you know women can just turn it on you
know uh that's why there's
i get annoyed when guys a [ __ ] about
women's feelings like how women are so
emotional they have all these feelings
and i'm like
yeah but
thank god because if they didn't they
wouldn't be with us you think they're
with us for our looks they can see
through it you know they can they can
see other [ __ ] in men because of those
feelings like he's ambitious or he's
funny or whatever and then i have this
whole act out about like i know a girl
she's obsessed with smart men
and i'm like i get it but how does that
play out in the bedroom because a lot of
[ __ ] men find sexy you can do in the
bedroom you know like legs or tits but
the [ __ ] women find sexy like
intelligence is some guy like uh
hypotenuse
and that hits but
the feelings are what women like that's
the only reason they're with us it's not
it's not my uh thin dick and and 5 10.
you know there's something about
there's something about
like saying something
very observant you know like you're
saying something like uh
you
do you show how informed you are while
you're [ __ ] her oh yeah you're just
like and you're like oh what's happening
ukraine is horrible right now
yeah i don't know if you saw the news
story she's like oh my god turn me over
there's always a lot of like you know
geometry trigonometry going on so maybe
if you can do the math right the g
species you're fine right there you go
physics
yeah if i put the leg like this i don't
know if you remember when you lost your
virginity but it's
the angles are weird of course yeah
you're new you know you're green so
sometimes i wish i had the calculus
education too right you know make that
right the first time they really teach
everything but the [ __ ] you need
can we get one class on how to angle
yourself in the push-up position yes
please
can we get one taxes cunnilingus there's
all kinds i don't i don't need algebra i
had a great coach who would do the
health class and dude he was so funny he
had he had george carlin's voice he was
a bearded cranky jew who played uh
college uh baseball for memphis and he
would just say [ __ ] up [ __ ] and then
be like oh i'm racist he goes i went to
memphis
14 black guys 10 whites
one jew
i feel like uh no one called you right
right
but he was just [ __ ] he would just
like pick fights or he'd do like he'd do
the thing we'd like put his finger
through the the oh my god [ __ ] bricks
he was such a classic uh he was so funny
that's great that wouldn't fly down jim
no no dude he got he got laid off i mean
oh he got another job he was great but i
mean the guy who was in charge hated him
he was so funny
i mean he was legitimately a funny dude
i hope he's all right he's all right
he's doing well he sent me a message
recently he's doing he's doing well oh
wow you keep in touch
good to keep in touch i agree i agree
i don't i don't know anybody from uh any
teacher i mean i had a teacher come to
my show in kentucky i was shocked that's
crazy how's it run on yeah what was that
like my teachers hated me yeah yeah did
they know they were coming to see you
yeah i mean how [ __ ] weird would that
be yeah holy [ __ ] i taught this guy
english in seventh grade yeah yeah of
course
he lives in kentucky he's always going
to play there and he's welcome yeah yeah
it's nice it sounds like he went to a
good school yeah i did yeah yeah i went
to public school it was a lot of like
[ __ ] you sit down you know well there's
that too but yeah i think i think also
it's like they didn't like me a lot of
them at the time and now they're like oh
he's all right oh i think it's a lot of
like he grew right
i guess i never grew
i didn't like it
i had a teacher miss o'dwyer and one
time she she was like we were talking
about something she goes what does that
mean and i go miss o'dwar you got to get
out more
that's it detention i'm like what that's
it one time i said up yours i didn't
know what it meant i just saw bill
murray say it and i got in trouble for
that
detention's really changed because we
did with detention now
brittany griner's in detention right
right the attention back in the day it
was [ __ ] it was an hour an hour after
school
no talking to your friends that you can
go home it wasn't you're in russia
and you're gonna be politicized it felt
like it though you're like oh detention
a whole hour and you of course we all
saw the jud nelson scene and brothers
clubs here like come at me
oh this summer let's go in the second
it's over you're like [ __ ] i ruined my
hole yeah all my plans are shot i was
trying to be jud nelson in breakfast
club
you see this that's what you get for
spilling paint in the garage
i've seen that movie too he was a
[ __ ] man he was the coolest judd
nelson for life dude when he shoved his
head in the crotch that was big oh yeah
molly ringwald oh yeah
she was one fine piece of ace
what about the scene where he's walking
through the ventilation duct or crawling
and he's like he tells a joke but he
never finishes it oh let's hear it
i don't know you got to pull it up but
as a kid i was like what's the punch
line because he falls through the
vent too busy looking up the crotch shot
here hold on oh yeah all right let's do
the joke that's assault brother yeah
let's see this is the joke
that's the salt brother anthony michael
hall yeah that was a really hot goth
trick
ali sheedy she was hot yeah she was uh
she had to figure it out painted the
drew a picture of snow and then user
dandruff that was the thing that i
remember most from that movie yeah why
or that the principal's so good he's
great he was in a ton of [ __ ] is it he
was getting money talks with chris
tucker he's in die hard yeah die hard
[Music]
bartender says i suppose you won't be
needing a drink
maybe lady
so now she's just holding a two-foot
salami yeah
and it's i'm guessing it's gonna be a
dirty joke yeah yeah
so immediately salami we think cox sure
but is this a well-known joke that
everybody in the audience is like oh
i've heard that
and we just we're too young or you gotta
go
could someone finish this unfinished
joke thank you god this is why the
internet comes in handy
i believe it's never intended to be
finished but i'm curious ah and it
starts with all right we just saw that i
need an answer ready blonde says anyone
don't read that blonde says i definitely
do after what just happened to me
bartender says i'm so sorry what
happened the blonde says well my
boyfriend and i were just about to make
love when out of nowhere the crazy
bastard says i'm gonna pound my favorite
[ __ ] with my giant sausage so i grabbed
them both and got the hell out of there
okay he was she was afraid he was gonna
[ __ ] the dog with the salami right
so this
it's not a great great joke but it's a
great set up to a joke like you would
expect like if you were just saying give
me the fr the front half of a joke right
it's pretty good that's a pretty good
i'm nervous when the setup's too big
it's like when is it the wind up so big
then you're kind of it's just building
it's building expectations agreed the
simpler the better a [ __ ] walks into a
bar says ouch yeah you know you're like
all right that's a joke
the horse walks into a bar why the long
face okay boom
um comments are saying yeah that was
home crafted comments are saying that
guy came up with himself oh it recently
revered in premier magazine that there
was no punch line according to judge
nelson i made the joke up
uh
judge nelson
clerk show do you ever see that it was
the honorable judge reinhold he was an
actual judge
so he says so we were trying to work
backward from that
uh what the joke
would have a punchline okay all right
well i feel better that it has no ending
because that was my whole life i was
just like i didn't like the favorite
[ __ ]
line anyway not my favorite no
all right well
i had a lot of salt today yeah what was
lunch
uh i i've just had like snacks oh
light stomach
me and him got a i got a barley soup and
a half of pastrami on rye where'd you go
ben's delicatessen good so good we've
gone there 10 times now is that chinese
place closed down for good i think so
yeah
all right well we got a patreon to do
all right well you guys have been great
make sure to uh subscribe to the patreon
we uh patreon.com we might be drunk pod
email us rex jokes
whatever uh peeves yeah we might be
drunk pod at gmail.com if you want to
send us [ __ ] gotham studios on 39 west
38th street mark you're hitting the road
man i'm on the road every weekend uh
coming to a town near you dc raleigh
cleveland chicago uh
denver phoenix irvine california um you
name it i'm all at dania beach
indianapolis i'm all over the road it's
gonna be a fun year
uh what else we got there addison improv
great austin paramount theatre for moon
tower
uh what else you got phoenix arizona
phoenix colusa california at some casino
that should be interesting
uh
madison improv in may that's dallas yeah
yeah bricktown is that say bricktown
yeah okay see that's good good club good
good room good crowd san jose improv
santa blah yeah so a lot of fun dates
mark normancomedy.com check out out to
lunch check out the stand-ups on netflix
and the merch is cooking we got koozies
we got those glasses people seem to be
enjoying the glasses i love the i love
the glasses i love the koozies they're
great uh yeah what do i got uh salt lake
city coming up
um what else
improv just added an la show but that's
that's the small room so it's going to
go fast is that beacon sold out i think
it is but they might just release some
new tickets because i some people are
asking like one by one so there might be
a cup a few tickets left
um what else nashville zanies albany
funny bone toronto
uh
providence chicago
tampa cleveland
all over that [ __ ] houston west palm we
got a makeup date in july really glad i
missed uh west palm in march and moved
it to july to july
right when you want to go to uh florida
uh all over the place so yeah san jose
improv as well so all over the all over
the states baby
samurail.com shows
pumped loving it so uh
yeah you got a new hour to put down on
wax oh yeah we're we're ironing out the
kinks so go see it now when it's hot
it's like bubbling bubbling over and
then you got to put it down like a dog
with rabies
so yeah sally you're good
sally's got some some gigs finally he's
back i'm back maybe
beard jew you still working at say less
am i allowed to say that yes you are so
we're going
uh uh my own uh recipe book coming out
soon
called bodega bartendings oh whoa
that fits with us pretty good
yeah we'll teach you how to make like
real nice drinks with anything you can
find at your local liquor store and
corner store so you don't have to get
too fancy and you can follow along with
us here hell yeah and our whiskey should
be coming out within the next couple
months christian maybe sooner if we're
lucky and we're lucky christopher
yeah christopher what did i say
christian all right well he's a
religious man
well we'll see you guys thank you we
love you thank you guys keep drinking
[Music]
and i get down in the same way
up on the roof like a cob's coming and
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new orleans
this woman doesn't look like i remember
her and i get down in the same way
we might
be
true
[Music]
you